le domaine de la valette tout en
couleurs depuis plus de quinze jours des
artistes venus du monde entier font
référence à la tragique histoire du site
témoin du régime totalitaire de franco
sur ce mur le brésilien casey se moque
des dictateurs maduro trump ou encore
ball sonar au menu d'une tronçonneuse
pour symboliser son laxisme face à la
déforestation au brésil en portage
ok peu importe les visages présentés
c'est le mur de la répression du
totalitarisme et de tout ce qu'on a vécu
de pire à l'époque de franco et qui
malheureusement est totalement présent
dans la société d'aujourd'hui
quarante ans après la mort de franco les
organisateurs ont invité une trentaine
d'artistes parmi eux des espagnols
[Musique]
la fresque qui est derrière nous c'est
celle de maria herreros qui est une
artiste de valence et capin sous le
visage de son grand père qui était
soldat républicain pendant la guerre
civile et qui a écrit en fait un journal
intime où il raconte tout ça période
durant la guerre civile
du coup à gauche on à la première page
et à droite la dernière page
et ça raconte en fait la dureté et on va
dire vraiment l'impact que cela a eu sur
la population espagnole
au programme ce week-end des conférences
de la musique des battles de graffeurs
être éphémère c'est l'essence même du
street art dimanche matin voiture et
containers seront colorés et les bals en
dit tout tous des bons plaît